all right tether executives are
reportedly facing a department of
justice
criminal probe for bank fraud according
to bloomberg
a story published today claims that the
department of justice is probing tether
on whether its executives committed bank
fraud as you know we've been doing a
twitter investigation
here on the podcast for the past couple
weeks maybe even months now
and uh slowly but surely we're figuring
out how this stable coin
a coin a cryptocurrency that's backed
reportedly
dollar for dollar with the u.s dollar
and we found out that they no longer do
that they've got a collection of assets
uh well this is a separate issue it
seems
then their holdings and this is on top
of their top two executives being mia
and the two uh two other executives who
are very vocal on twitter their
general counsel and their cto being on
cnbc
last week and never mentioning anything
about this
so this is typically what happens in the
case of a fraud
or people who were playing fast and
loose with
regulations we don't know what this is
at the very least it seems like they're
uh lucy goosey with regulations here
obviously the new york attorney general
had sanctioned previously and come to a
settlement with tether
because they lied about being one for
one peg to the dollar
they keep brushing that off but
bloomberg published an article today
which claimed that the department of
justice is in fact probing tether on
whether
its executives committed bank fraud and
it looks like someone at the doj leaked
this information to bloomberg
which cited three unnamed sources
familiar with the matter now again
unnamed sources but there's three of
them and there's been all this smoke
around tether and there's in fact been
fired with the new york attorney general
banning tether from working with new
york
residents so there is actually a fire
here and the question is how big is the
fire
there's a ton of smoke and all of the
different
journalistic entities out there with any
kind of an investigative group or
sources
are starting to ping people that's
typically what happens in these kind of
cases that happen with theranose with
the wall street journal and other
sources and these kind of things with
made off you know they go from being on
the fringe
to becoming mainstream and we'll see if
this ends like there knows or made off
or
if they just put it behind them and it's
a speeding ticket
it doesn't feel like a speeding ticket
to me at this point it feels like
something a little more serious perhaps
with the risk of ruin
we'll get into that but according to the
article federal prosecutors are not
going after tether for any recent crimes
okay so this is something historical
according to the article
the doj is reportedly and this is a
quote
focused on conduct that occurred years
ago
when tether was in its more nascent
stages specifically
federal prosecutors are scrutinizing
whether tether concealed from banks
that transactions were linked to crypto
this seems
like something they would do i'll be
totally honest in many crypto exchanges
people who are trying to get their money
into the crypto economy need an on-ramp
what's the on-ramp typically it's wiring
money from your bank
uh and then buying that crypto or i
guess you could send a check or do an
ach
somehow getting your money into this
casino
is the issue now banks who are very very
particular about who they do business
with here in the united states because
of kyc know your customer
and anti-money laundering um statutes
and regulations
these things are very acute they come
with the risk of ruin
banks can be shut down for not following
these and and in fact people can go to
jail for money laundering obviously and
not knowing where their customers are
so specifically federal prosecutors are
scrutinizing
again this is the quote whether tether
concealed from banks
that transactions were linked to crypto
here's the quote the current focus on
bank for it suggests prosecutors
may have moved on from pursuing a case
tied to market manipulation
so there's also been this theory that
the printing of tethers
was occurring maybe out of sync with
reality in some way and then that was
being used in a coordinated way
to raise the price of bitcoin i believe
that bitcoin has been manipulated many
times
uh if you are looking at an anonymous
cryptocurrency or a pseudo-anonymous one
it's really easy
to paint the tape and create order flow
that's not real
to boost up the attention of
this particular currency and in fact
there is a group on telegram
where they pump crypto assets you know
on a weekly or monthly basis
and everybody's supposed to buy at the
same time and hold forever
and you know how this goes it's just
standard pump and dump nonsense so
maybe this isn't about tether
manipulating the price of
uh bitcoin or ethereum and maybe it's
not about
their holdings in commercial paper maybe
from china maybe
some fugazi paper who knows what's going
on there because they
won't simply tell us if tether
had nothing to hide they would simply
say here's our commercial paper
they on cnbc said they have
international paper but they wouldn't
specifically say it's china
we've had people on the program talk
about they think it's chinese paper
who knows but if it is chinese paper and
china's coming apart right now
in terms of entrepreneurship in terms of
ipos and the government
closing ranks i mean what if the
government in china just says hey yeah
your commercial paper is not worth
anything here
or what if they were buying commercial
paper that was you know worth 10 cents
on the dollar but it appears to be
a hundred dollars but they paid ten
dollars for it you get the idea there's
all kinds of weird stuff that occurs
if you are or your mind wanders to
places when
you don't disclose the holdings that
they have
so i said last week on episode 1250
after we saw the cnbc interview that i
felt
that the general counsel and cto they
did not seem like they were being this
is just my read on it as a poker player
they didn't seem like they were super
confident or being upfront about it so i
think they might be in a clean up
process
i also have a question that i would have
asked which is
to the cto are you involved in the
purchase of commercial paper
have you ever been involved in the
purchase of a commercial paper have you
ever
seen the commercial paper held
by tether yes or no when is the last
time
you had access to that commercial paper
it may turn out that the cto is the fall
guy maybe the cto
has never seen any of this paper
and they're putting him out there to
take the daggers and to take the bullets
take the arrows for the you know ceo
and cfo who nobody's seen because
they are media shy according to
the uh cto and general counsel uh when
they were on cnbc they're like yeah they
don't like to be in the limelight
trust me if my company or any normal
person's company was under this amount
of scrutiny
doj new york attorney general jim cramer
financial times bloomberg
you know coffeezilla myself everybody
asking these questions constantly the
ceo
would of course come forward and say i'm
the ceo here's what's going on at my
company i
am the cfo the buck stops at my desk
here is what's happening with our
company if the cfo and the ceo will not
talk
to the press uh and to their customers
publicly
and address these issues that kind of
for me that's the end of the line
i would never participate in any of
these financial systems
if the ceo and the cfo are you know
um in the worst case on the lam and
afraid of getting arrested
which who knows maybe this doj is the
reason they're not talking
and the reason nobody knows where they
are or their location seems to be
a mystery because maybe they're in a
jurisdiction where
they don't have an extradition treaty
who knows again when you have this kind
of opaqueness
in you know a serious situation it's
pretty clear to me what's going on
if anybody in my family or anybody who
was a friend said
should i do business with a company that
the new york attorney general has banned
from new york
that's under doj investigation that will
not answer questions that will
not just tell you what's going on in
their ceo and cfo
are m.i.a press shy
on the lam who knows what the accurate
description here is i would say
absolutely not
it's time for another r crowd deal of
the week
right now you can join our crowd's
investment in ripple
according to the deal memo ripple is an
established innovator in the rapidly
growing
multi-billion dollar dairy alternative
market ripple offers alternatives to
milk
protein shakes creamer and more with
proprietary tech that lowers impurities
for superior taste and nutrition
you can get in early on ripple and other
unique opportunities
by signing up for free at rcrowd.com
twist by the way did you know that our
crowd investors were
able to get into some of the best ipos
of 2019 and 2020 they benefited from
companies ipointing like
beyond meat and lemonade and some of our
crowds companies have been acquired by
buyers like
intel nike microsoft oracle and uber yum
yum
with our crowd accredited investors can
invest directly and easily in startups
early before they ipo or get bought
as you review deals you have access to
our crowd's investor relations team
who you can talk to directly on the
phone about your personal
investment goals again the or crowd
account
is free just go to o-u-r-c-r-o-w-d dot
com
slash twist